We're going to touch on another
one of my passions here,
and it's a growing passion.
I still consider myself
a bit of a beginner
when it comes to containers.
We're going to talk about
Kubernetes and Docker.
I want to check what's going on.
Who here has worked
with containers before?
That's actually
about as expected.
Don't worry, we're going
to do some overview,
so if you don't know the
intricacies of containers
you'll get a good
summary, hopefully.
So what are containers
and how can they
help us be better developers?
I'm going to start
with the summary
because that's the most
important part, obviously.
A container raises
the abstraction level
for how you develop.
When you're developing on
traditional virtual machines,
you are actually interacting
with idealized hardware.
Right?
You're interacting with the
operating system, the network,
the disk, what have you.
It's fairly well tied
into the environment
on which you're running.
You have to know
the ins and outs,
whether there are any
gotchas, et cetera.
And what happens is
this becomes kind
of like an octopus intertwined
with the environment.
That's not really ideal.
So containers separate out your
application from where it runs.
That's like the
most powerful thing
that I can say about containers.
So instead of developing on
top of the idealized hardware,
you're developing against an
idealized operating system,
a static Linux
environment when you're
developing with containers.
It allows you to really
develop in a more generic way
that can run more places.
You wind up with this
kind of hermetically
sealed-- which I think
is an awesome phrase
to describe containers--
a hermetically sealed
application.
This allows you to
really dive into what's
going on in your
application because it's
lifted up outside
of the environment.
We'll get into a
little bit more detail.
So why do we care?
Why do developers
care about containers?
The first reason is stress.
Who here is stressed?
I am so stressed I
can't even tell you.
We deal with stress on a day
to day basis, and often times
it comes from our deployments.
Right?
I remember I once had a bug
in my production system.
This is before I joined Google.
I once had a bug in
my production system
that only existed there.
It didn't occur in my
development environment.
It didn't occur in
staging or test.
Only in production.
That strikes fear into
the heart of a developer.
Like ice running
through your veins.
Because it's so hard to debug.
It's an environment issue.
I was combing through
code and I actually
didn't find anything because
the bug was not in the code.
It was in the build scripts,
which you can argue is code.
I'll grant you that.
So these reliable
deployments, when
you're operating
with containers,
it means that your
development environment is
the same as your staging
or test environment,
is the same as your
production environment.
Because you're developing
against that idealized static
Linux environment.
The surface area for
bugs, while you can still
obviously introduce them
into your applications,
it's dramatically reduced.
That just makes people
happy and lifts stress.
So containers, less stress.
The other reason is
that it is portable.
You can take a container with
your deployable application
and move it from one
environment to another.
So you may decide to run
Compute Engine or another cloud
provider.
But with containers
you can easily
move between different
environments,
different providers.
This is awesome.
This is great.
What it means is you can
pursue a multi-cloud approach,
if you want.
Oftentimes that may, indeed,
be the path you take.
You can decide to do a hybrid
cloud, a private cloud,
and then switch from one to
the other when the case may be.
We've done a lot of
work with Compute Engine
to make sure it's
awesome and that it's
a great place for
you to develop,
but we want you to be there
because you want to be there,
not because it's hard to move.
So you get to pick your
cloud, where you run,
based on its merits.
That puts the power
back into your hands.
And that's fantastic.
That's the way it should be.
The last reason is
because micro services.
Containers make it easier
for you to separate out
your application into
smaller components that
are far more like Lego
than monolithic structures.
This means you can
manage them much easier.
You can debug a micro
service far more easily
than you can debug a
monolithic application.
It makes it easier to upgrade.
You can slowly,
incrementally improve
what you're offering
to your users.
And make sure and know that your
surface area for regressions
is low.
Then of course you can
mix in other services
easily and safely.
However, if you do encounter a
regression based on an upgrade,
containers also make it
really easy to roll back.
This is a slide that you
did see in the keynote,
but everything at Google
runs in a container.
Everything.
We've been long-term
fans of containers.
And why is that?
What do containers give us
that we love so very much?
We've been doing this kind
of hyper scale deployments,
these hyper scale services.
To be most efficient
we need to make
as much use of our
resources as possible.
So the machines
that we run, we want
them to be as close to
100% capacity as possible.
Containers let us do that.
If we have a really
high priority
job that we want to run, we can
put that on the same machine
as a low priority job, but
in their own containers.
That means that the
low priority job
won't consume the resources
of the high priority one.
And the resource isolation
means they're not
going to run up into each
other on another level.
It also means that we
get a lot of insight
into how our
applications are running.
Is one application eating
up a lot of disk space?
It could be.
And because it's running in
its own container we can drill
down, find out which
application that is
and why it's doing that.
It gives us resource accounting.
Then we can, of course,
talk to our engineers
and create that
nice feedback loop
between how an application
runs and how it's developed.
Like I said, we're big
fans of containers.
We run over 2 billion per week.
Things like Gmail, Search,
Drive all run in containers.
In fact, our Compute
Engine, Virtual Machines,
run in containers as well.
That's something.
We're saying, we're throwing
our experience, our weight
behind this technology and
telling you we're big fans.
So let's talk a little bit
about the stack at Google.
The Google cluster
management stack
is comprised of two sections,
the section in blue,
and the section in what
I'm going to call marigold.
That seems like that color.
So at the base you've
got the managed base
OS and the node
container manager.
So these two things
are what are deployed
on every single machine
in our data centers.
Every single one.
The schedules
containers is everything
that we want to run
on our machines.
And the cluster
scheduler figures out
where and when that happens.
So let's talk out
the blue section.
This is essentially what
we've released in May
as our Container Optimized
Virtual Machine Image,
and that is a mouthful.
So this means that you can go
from an imperative approach
to a declarative one.
And what does that mean?
We might be at the point
where I say-- sorry,
I apparently will say sorry--
where I say to a machine,
I want you to run this software,
do these tasks and shut down.
If I want to move that into a
declarative approach you say,
I expect this machine to be
running, doing these tasks
and shutting down
once that happens.
It's a really subtle
change, isn't it?
It's hard to parse.
It's almost more of
a psychological shift
than a technological one.
It means you can go to expecting
what your machine should
be doing instead
of feeling like you
have to tell them every time.
So what does that
actually look like?
Let's go through a
command line example.
Who here uses Apache web server?
Nginx?
So Nginx is a really
lightweight web server.
It's easy to install,
easy to spin up,
and we've been using it for
some of our examples lately.
We're going to call in
to the cloud sdk gcloud.
We're going to create a Compute
Engine instance, a Compute
Engine Virtual Machine.
We're going to call
it My Nginx Container.
And we're going to take some
configuration information
from this containers.yaml file.
We'll locate it in a zone.
We're going to use
a small instance.
It's a lightweight web server.
We don't need a big one.
Best practices say, always use
the right tool for the job.
And then we're going to use
our container optimized VM,
and that's what that
dash, dash, image,
really long string that I
don't really want to say.
And we're going
to contain create
a container running Ngninx.
Pretty simple.
But what is in this
container's .yaml file?
That's it.
We've got a nice,
structured specification
of what we want to happen
inside of the container.
We want to use the Nginx image.
We're going to call it www.
And we're going to
open up a standard port
to serve traffic over.
We're mapping 80 to 80/80.
And that will let us go ahead
and stand up a nice web server
inside of a container.
But let's make it a little
bit more complicated, not very
much.
Let's say, OK but let's go
back to the best practices.
We should also open up https.
We can do that simply by adding
another section under the ports
and open up port 443.
So now we have a nice
web server serving
traffic over http or https.
Let's get a little
bit more complicated.
Now this is great
for a web server,
but what if you've got two
functions maybe sharing
some data, but they comprise
one overall application.
So that's what we call a pod.
We've got the web
server, the www,
and we've got a data loader
that takes in, say, new things
that you want to serve.
So it's going to write
that to the data shard.
They work nicely together
and they can actually
function as a unit with this
thing we're calling a pod.
So as you can see,
the web server, www,
mounts up our data shard, but
it doesn't need to write to it.
It's just going to be read only.
Whereas, the data loader
does need to write,
so obviously we
don't have that line.
That's the conceptual
unit a pod.
What does this look like?
On the virtual machine itself
we've got a couple of sections.
We've got what Google provides
and we've got what you provide.
On the left is all
Google provided.
You can see it's
kind of haphazard.
We've got the managed base OS.
We've got the monitoring
agent, the logging agent.
But we've also got
Docker running.
It's already running on
our container optimized
virtual machine images.
It's also got a couple
of processes running,
likes sshd and init.
On the right hand side is
the container environment
that we talked about right
on top of that base OS,
and we've got the user
app, what you create.
So let's step out
back into scheduling.
The job of the
cluster scheduler is
to figure out what resources
are available to it
and figure out where
the best place is
for you to run your job.
So you can say to it,
I need x cores, y ram
and, let's say, z
amount of disk that I
want associated
with this container.
It'll say, OK cool.
That's awesome.
I think I can do that,
let me go find a place.
And it'll find a place
where it can run happily.
This is where
Kubernetes comes in.
So Kubernetes is an
open source project.
It's developed out
in the open on GitHub
You can go, clone
it, fork it today.
And we'll give you a link
to that at the very end,
so don't worry about searching.
It's actually ancient Greek--
an etymological sidetrack--
for "pilot" or "helmsman".
We're a little bit
of nerds at Google,
I don't know if you could tell.
What it does is it's
a Cluster Manager.
It's what we were talking
about in the marigold.
Do we have any
gophers in the room?
All right.
How many of you are confused
by the term "gopher"?
OK.
So gopher is what
we generally called
people who develop and go.
You'll be happy to know
that Kubernetes is actually
implemented in the go
programming language.
It allows you to manage
applications and not machines.
We developed it out in the
open for a couple of reasons.
We don't think we
can go it alone.
We want to make
sure that we gather
the expertise necessary to make
this an awesome open source
project for everyone.
That means being able
to run it wherever
you want, whether you
want to run it locally,
on your own cloud, on Google's
cloud-- obviously we've
done a lot of work to
make it run great there--
or on a different provider.
Like Tom just mentioned,
we've gotten a lot of interest
from other companies who are
becoming active committers
on the project, and
that's so awesome to see.
Microsoft, IBM, Red Hat, Docker,
Mesosphere, SaltStack , CoreOS,
and I've run out of breath
so we're going to stop there.
And you, too, can submit
pull requests as well.
You can become a
contributor for Kubernetes.
So I encourage you
to check it out.
So what does it
actually look like?
With Kubernetes it
provides a scheduler layer.
It lets you schedule
work in the way
that we were talking about
in a declarative manner,
but you don't need to know
what machine you're running on.
That's almost irrelevant, right?
So you interact with the
Kubernetes Master/Scheduler
whenever you want
to interact with it.
So you tell it what
pod you want to run.
In this case we've got a
Web Server and a Log Roller,
and it'll schedule the
work out to machines.
And if all you need is
a few of these pods,
maybe you're developing a small
application, that's great.
That's probably
all you need to do.
But if you've got a
more complex application
that's going to be too much to
handle, at least rationally.
So right here we've
got a bunch of pods.
We've got some front ends, we've
got some back ends, hopefully
all working in some
sort of harmony.
But we want to make it easier.
That's where labels and
selectors come into play.
It's a really simple concept.
We assign labels to pods.
In this case we've got
two types of labels.
We've got front
end and back end.
And here we're going to
select all of the front ends
that we've got running in
our Kubernetes cluster.
So you can see all of the
front ends are lit up and green
and the back ends
have been deselected.
But wait, there's more.
You can do a more complex query.
And you only want to select
the production front ends.
So you can select on both
labels, the stage and the role
label.
And again, three front
ends have dropped away
and we're left with all of
the production front ends.
OK.
So now you have a set of pods.
You can interact with a set of
pods in your Kubernetes cluster
and you want to
do something cool.
You can do that with
the replica controller.
This takes a template, this kind
of pre-defined cookie cutter
type thing, and a label
selector, and a set of pods
and a number of replicas.
What it does is it
keeps maintaining
the containers, the pods, to
comply with that cookie cutter.
So right here you can see
we've got four replicas,
and, lo and behold, we have
four production front ends.
OK.
But you know what?
I decided that's way too many.
It's a small application.
I don't need four front ends.
I want to drop it down to one.
So the replica
controller is constantly
monitoring and saying,
hey is my expected state
the same as my actual state?
And in this case, I want
to change it to one.
So I update and the replica
controller will say, oh wait.
I've got four.
I only need one.
That's far too many.
Let me kill three, and
we're left with one.
I've clearly made
a drastic error.
It was not a good idea
to drop it down to one
so I'll increase it to three.
Again, our expected
state is different
than our actual state.
Let's up it.
Let's create a couple more
containers until our state is
the right one.
Right now we've only been
talking about the front ends,
the production front
ends, and obviously
there were back ends
in our cluster as well.
So we need a way to access
both in an abstracted manner.
We need a way to access
our production front ends
and our production back
ends in an abstract way.
That's what we do with services.
A service is basically a way for
you to access your set of pods.
You access them
through an endpoint.
In this case, for the back ends,
we access them on port 9,000.
The front ends can
talk to that endpoint.
It doesn't matter how
many pods there are there.
It's going to load
balance anything that
comes in over that port
across the ones that exist.
So it's a nice easy way.
Again, you don't need to
care how many containers
are running, you just
need a way to interact
with the ones that are.
So who wants to do a demo?
OK.
Awesome.
So no demo in tech is
complete without cats.
Right?
Yeah, I didn't think so.
Can we switch to
the demo, please?
Let me unlock my machine
and we will get there.
Awesome.
So these are our cats.
We've got a Kubernetes cluster
running, a simple web server.
And these are actually
running on Compute Engine.
This is basically showing
off what the pods are doing.
Not necessarily
your end goal here,
but it's good for this purpose.
I do have a confession to make.
I'm not a cat person.
I'm sorry.
I'm not a cat person,
so what I want to do
is replace all of these cats
with pictures of a nautilus
instead.
That's so much cooler
than cats, I'm sorry.
So what I'm going to do is pull.
We've got a data
file that's telling
us which picture to use.
I'm going to modify it.
And you can see here currently
it's pulling kitten.jpg
and we're going to
make it nautilus.
Let's see if I
spelled that right.
Somebody want to spell check me?
Now what we're going
to do is actually
go ahead and build
the Docker image.
So I'm going to build
it, build the container.
It's going to finish
really rapidly,
so I'm going to go
ahead and push it.
It's going to go
ahead and do this,
but you'll notice that
we still have our cats.
It's not actually changing
anything with Kubernetes.
I could refresh the page.
It's not going to
matter because we
haven't told it to do anything.
We haven't told it to update.
So while that's
actually pushing,
because it takes a
little bit of time,
I'm just going to show
you that indeed we
are still serving up kitten.jpg.
In fact, if we
take this away you
can see that we're running
Nginx inside our container.
So let's see.
We're on most in
there, anticipating
just a couple minutes.
Not a minute, like
a couple seconds.
That would be insane.
And we've finished.
Now we can go ahead and interact
with Kubernetes to update.
So I've created a link to my
command line to this utility
and I'm going to do
a rolling update.
As anybody who's done
production updates,
you don't want to
do it all at once
because everything will go down.
It's generally regarded
as a bad thing.
Generally.
So we're going to interact
with the data controller,
and we're going to do an
update interval of 10 seconds.
It is also way too
fast for production.
Everything will go
down if you do this.
However, since I've got less
than five minutes to go,
I'm going to go ahead and
live life on the edge.
It's going to interact
with the Kubernetes API.
We're going to go back here
and you can see already
that we have containers
dropping off.
As they come back
up, hopefully will
be serving an image that
will contribute to my plan
to replace all pictures
of cats on the internet
with pictures of a nautilus.
Sorry cat people.
I apologize.
So you see again, because our
update interval is so short,
we do not have all of
our containers running
at once, all of our
pods running at once.
Clearly you want to do
something a little bit more
sane as your update interval.
Once it comes back up it
will pull down the image.
We've got the pods running.
It hasn't yet started serving.
That will come back
as things progress.
That will happen
in the background.
I do just want to show you
that we can, actually--
because these are just Compute
Engine virtual machines--
we can ssh into the vm's.
So let's go ahead and do that.
Let's ssh into Kubernetes
minion-- ha ha ha,
the thread is complete-- one.
I've always wanted a minion.
This is why I went
to grad school.
I wanted minions.
We're now inside of
a Kubernetes minion.
As you can see, my command
prompt completely changed
because I'm running
a different shell.
We can take a look
at what's going on.
Let's do sudo docker ps.
And you can see, oh, because
it's such big font here,
but this is our Nginx server.
You can see.
We've got that.
Now remember that
that started with bd8.
OK?
So I'm going to kill it.
That's pretty much all you get
when you kill a Docker process.
So let's go back and do a ps.
Now you can see the
Nginx is not there.
But hey, didn't we say we wanted
four running at any given time?
So shouldn't it come back up?
And, in fact, it did.
And now it starts with ea9.
We have satisfied the replica
controller's requirements.
It monitored, it fixed,
and we're good to go.
So if we could switch back
to the slides, please?
So that's kind of the
magic that is Kubernetes.
It's a great open
source project.
We're excited to see
where it goes next.
So in summary, we've had a lot
of experiences over the last 10
years with containers.
Kubernetes is really our effort
to bring those experiences out
into the open source
community, as well
as get other experiences
and other use cases.
So tell us what you
want to see out of it.
File bugs, file issues,
and send us pull requests.
We're happy to see them.
Here are just some resources.
This is our
Kubernetes repository,
our container optimized
virtual machine images.
We're on Free Node.
So if you want to chat with
us, it's Google-containers.
Thanks everyone.